hey everybody welcome to another
rollback today is one of my all-time
favorite episodes it's from July of 2014
and it highlights the life of a man who
broke free from a life of quiet
desperation
born John Kitchen slo-mo is a spry and
vigorous 79 year old dude who is this
former successful neurologist turned
happiness Guru who and this is no joke
rollerblades in slow motion along the
San Diego coast which is basically most
of what he does
unable to continue his former life
slo-mo quit his job he sold all of his
possessions and made a simple
self-promise to slow down and start
smelling the roses with One Singular
fundamental premise
do what you love
for John this edict translated to one
very specific activity rollerblading all
day every day
this conversation is wild it's about
life transformation it's about finding
joy and contentment
it's about living in the moment
meditation community and so much more
and though this was recorded eight years
ago now I can assure you that slow-mo is
still out there getting after it every
single day so it is my honor and it's my
pleasure to bring you the story of
slo-mo
hey call me slow mo slow mo all right
why not right exactly why not well uh
there's a difference
tell me the difference
the nickname is much more meaningful
because it applies to the person you
earned it
yeah it but you could say you earned it
but it's from a different part of your
family
it's from the world of strangers it's
given to you by people who were not
in all likelihood not family members and
they're relating to you they begin to
relate to you first as an unknown
and then they identified you as an
abstract which is more in the category
of a person so
um to me
uh
it's a stage of development in a person
is to separate him from his uh the
objective uh credentialed sort of legal
so yeah the moniker that is placed upon
you uh without your involvement at Birth
versus sort of the true kind of
actualized self that the world recognize
you as being and it's parallel
to the um
dichotomy of experience in yourself
during the first phase of your life
as an object
even though you you're subjective you
experience yourself as an object in the
world
but as you evolve and the latter half of
the life
you begin to experience yourself as a
subjective entity
in a world which is objective
and separated
and
um
these Sports
which are in a special category nine
team sports sports which are
um
individual
activities which are individual
evolved during that lifetime
so that as a person ages
what appears to be an activity in the
objective world
becomes a type of activity in a
subjective World which this person
spends his time more and more in a state
of mind which is similar to worship as
opposed to the state of mind
that he would have had in the earlier
phase of his life when participating in
action he would be an aggressive and an
aggressive
State of Mind fixed on the external
World it goes to this I mean you're you
know a lot of what your life is about is
dichotomies and and more specifically
the dichotomy of the Zone versus the
non-zone I read your Manifesto yeah
Adam and and sort of the use of the this
word Zone as being expansive
you know really encompassing what you
know maybe in more mainstream circles
would be just known as God or or the
universe or whatever word you want to
place upon it higher power and the idea
of the subjectivity that goes hand in
hand with being in the zone or being
merged with the Zone versus the
objectivity of the non-zone state of
sort of being you know in the world
that's right right exactly so so in in
in the most simplistic terms if you
could sort of expand on that idea
explain explain really what you're
getting at with that
okay
um well in all the activities of life
this particular dualism exists where a
person uh can observe something in the
zone and or experience the zone
and it's quite different than the
non-zone all right
um
if you look at all those activities they
all have a set of
um intelligent and wise people who
discover the Zone within that activity
now the one I like I like to see of
people experience the zone is in the
spectacular Sports
that we get to observe on television
well that's where it's most readily kind
of appearance to the eye right yeah
um it first occurred to me what was
happening when I watched that movie but
uh with a Chariots of Fire and one of my
favorites yeah you remember when the uh
the runner fell
during I think it was an 880 run and his
friends were in the audience
he fell and then he got up and began to
try to catch up with the other Runners
and Van Galis who was doing the music
switches him into slow motion he's going
in slow motion though he's gaining on
these other runners
and the cameraman switches it to the
crowd
and his friends are standing up and what
the girl at one of the women says
do you see it
or something to that effect
and what they were seeing
really interests me
because I think that's what we saw when
we watch Michael Jordan
perform in the zone we were seeing
something
in the way that Amazing Grace uses the
word vision
we were experiencing something
attached to vision
which was in another world
that is the the person who was it's we
were watching someone in a pure state of
worship
and that's impressive and matter of fact
that's one reason I think some of the
people lined the streets of Rome when
the pope goes up and down I think he's
supposed to be
and I say supposed to be
relatively close at least a
representation of a state of worship but
the athlete when he's hitting three
pointers saying basketball say four or
five three pointers in a row
he is almost by definition in the what
he calls the zone
right and the subjectivity aspect of it
is that time is not a linear construct
time is more an elastic idea and and
it's an expansive place for the present
we're past and future are no longer
whereas in the non-zone the sort of
logical thinking brain and the way we
kind of carry ourselves through the
world we're basically spending all of
our time thinking about the past or
projecting us for the future right so so
so it's really
it's kind of come into Vogue lately like
it's it's sort of been captured now now
it's called The Flow State or is it out
about it and a lot of scientists
studying it from a non-zone perspective
I would imagine but the idea being like
how can we access more of this zone-like
state in our own daily life it's a
spiritual practice it's not something
that can be accessed through the
thinking mind you know I think that
uh any of us and correct me because I
haven't really tested the idea but
um
we could say what is the purpose of our
life
the first thing the first purpose
is to achieve some method
to experience the zone
and then try to do everything you can
from within the Zone because the zone is
a Superior State of Mind and it will
produce the best Athletics the best
behavior for instance the problems that
we're having in our country is that
we're we're we've almost divorced The
Zone entirely
from uh International and National
politics
that there's no
Zone okay
we're living in a country that's passed
into the non-zone right and uh in a way
the people the great athletes of which I
would include you and the other people
that are in their own
way experience and tremendous Feats of
athletic prowess
they are obviously
a a new to me the manifestation of a new
type of worship that's taking place as
they've been pushed a little bit to the
edge of the society in other words
they're not dominating the zones not
dominating people in the zone we watch
it in athletics and all but uh it's not
the idea of people so it's left a lot of
people's ownless so to speak there I
mean if if you think about it there's
absent Mandela there's not a single
exemplary person in the world
that we all would agree and can now in
our individual lives sure
but to think that the world
has been in our lifetime bereft
of really a lot of great people from a
leadership perspective yes I mean I
think that yes yeah on the fringes well
there's the athletes of course but I
would expand you know the zone
idea to anybody who has who has uh
created any a great creative expression
like the art any great artist will tell
you that they're painting or their
sculpture doesn't come from the
intellectual part of their mind they're
channeling it from something else and
that thinking mind goes away and they're
definitely in a Zone like state to
produce whatever it is that they're
trying to master right I reckon the yeah
I agree totally what she said I reckon
the point I'm trying to to make
is that the
practice of Life the practice of living
is
performed in some way which is either
falling into the non-zone or the zone
and if you take a society you can look
at the society itself
and see where the dominant part of the
society resides on that Spectrum and you
if there is something
that you could apply this knowledge to
not only to your personal life
but
um to
the way we analyze
um
any part of this life that's just
if you went to a country
you could say well how well how good is
that music and how well you could use
any criteria but what about
how close are they as a society so that
everybody can experience
his own
advancement into the Zone how Zoni is a
society in other words I think if you
use
um
uh some of these if you think of
societies there are societies that you
can point to
that had no Zone
in other words almost by definition a
Nazi Society decides to or perform
totally
in the world of objectivity and
um probably the opposite whatever the
opposite is you would think uh would say
that the society I would say like an
ancient uh Japanese Society or something
like that the idea was peace and Harmony
that some people could Advance
themselves spiritually that was the goal
you could tell that the thing was set up
to advance that goal and and probably
considering the depth
of poverty and all the rest of it during
the Dark Ages it was also
the society was set up to give the main
structure
to the individual who could pursue a
spiritual existence that is a zoning
existence okay I mean with they didn't
have the wherewithal to experience it
that we do now but you could see with
what they had
religion and spirituality in the state
of worship was held as the highest form
of right it was a cultural prerogative
yeah in modern times I mean you know
what are we left with I suppose in some
respects the you know the Tibetan Monks
or yeah uh certain you know removed
cultures that have been remained
Untouched by the Gestalt of you know us
sort of exporting our Western Way of
Life across the globe but it's only
small Pockets now and
and well I guess in certain respects
in Indian culture it's still spiritual
advancement is still regarded as as a
high form of living whereas it's really
not here I mean we talk about religion
but that's a different Beast altogether
right now I think in terms of that we
are doing it but we're doing it in our
way and our way
is the Athletics
of the single person the person who's
experiencing the zone now you can extend
that into art dance or whatever or maybe
uh just getting in in the State of Mind
by any method
but if you take that whole group
that is
um dedicated to experiencing the State
of Mind Of The Zone
and put them together
you could say
that that same group is the group that
put that same thing
as a priority in other societies and in
other times
it's one group and it's going through it
chained through time the last few
thousand years that it started somewhere
in Greece or or Troy you know out in
that area maybe in India and it's moved
across it went through Rome and it went
through it went up into Europe and it
came across okay this uh the state of
the the it's a this is a
some sort of
phenomenon which has been it's a state
of mind the shrinks would call it a
state of mind that's been carried
about human beings through this car to
over a thousands of several thousand
years
and
um
it just changes form sometimes it's
inside of cathedrals and churches
worshiping that way sometimes it's uh it
will in a lot of the Dark Ages it was
manifested in building beautiful
buildings the artists now are doing it
the ones that are contributing to the uh
they're making that are actually where
the Zone produces the art
um and that that might be an interesting
topic there's a lot that's
that's you don't I mean I could paint a
picture and not be in the zone right
okay in other words I might want to make
money which is
but anyway that's a whole nother subject
went on right but the the this idea of
tapping into a Oneness and a greater and
a power that's greater than than
yourself because as an athlete you know
I've certainly experienced that and
there's there's no way that you know I
know for a fact that the things that
I've been able to do as an athlete don't
come from my power into it it's only by
tapping into something larger than
myself you know I'm very very in touch
with that
um and I think that's a if you start to
talk about that then you start to get
maligned as some sort of no no no no but
you shouldn't you shouldn't because uh
that's what I mean right now the
pressure of the social conventions is
totally in favor of the non-zone you can
in other words you uh when George Bush
said that he'd learn more from they
asked him what single man that he
learned the most from he said Jesus
Christ
half the people responded with a nod
that that's absolutely the correct
answer
for anybody that really has spent time
reading the New Testament and then and
and thought in terms of other people
looked at his head that would have to
stand out
but the other half thought that it was a
cheated answer because it was used in
religion okay and so anytime a person
um even if he starts talking about
Buddha nowadays you know it you can't
even talk about Buddha right Buddha is
out of style even in California think of
that
I mean this like but the same group is
pursuing the worship they don't care
about what you call it they don't care
if you call it the Christ the
fundamental man the force the spirit
whatever it is they called it the soul
generically it's what people call the
soul and the scientists that dominate
the non-zone have declared for a long
time now that there is absolutely no
existence of the soul that this is a
myth
and even the uh the Buddhists and other
people a lot of them would would say
something to that effect so uh we're the
again it's the dichotomy of the nine
Zone and the Zone when you're in the
zone you never this and you can correct
me if this is if you agree with us I
disagree
you never question whether there's a
higher power of whether there's a God it
doesn't occur to you to question it it
doesn't occur to you to question that
you exist as a as an entity of some kind
of subjective something that could be
called a soul it those questions and
doubts only exist when the mind is in
the non-zone
and so why is this so difficult for us
as a culture to grasp I mean we're so
focused on you know our culture our
cultural priorities are to you know sort
of move up the corporate ladder and and
accumulate these material goods and you
know keep up with the Joneses and all
these sorts of things these are the
ideas and the thoughts and the mindset
that we walk around with on a daily
basis and this sort of Greater truth is
staring Us in the face and yet it's so
difficult to access for most people
I think it's like playing golf
everybody's playing the same course and
everybody has to get over this get
through the same set of traps you know
and frankly if you look at the big traps
the big traps are a Fame that's one of
them and money or power
and
um and and all the subdivisions of those
and all that but
those are the
uh if you use an old way of thinking
that we evolved
ontologically each of us would go
through an evolutionary involvement like
we start out close to say a chimpanzee
Behavior or something like that and we
gradually Advance through the king the
the king and you get to the top and the
top is some sort has some sort of benign
wise personality okay that's non-violent
um well in in that
well you're looking at it
um
hell I lost track of this idea
all right we can get back to it but I
want to get it I want to get into your
story a little bit because you were uh
you weren't always the philosopher king
that you are now right so let's let's
take it back I mean I want to hear uh
you know I want to get into the
evolution of what what uh you know
forged this identity known as slo-mo so
you know back in the South growing up on
the dairy farm and we're going to you
know going to medical school and you
know what your life was like as a
practicing uh you were a neurologist
right so yeah I was here about that
well
it has I started out on a little farm
but it was looking back on it
it was an ideal place
for a child to grow up on
as a matter of fact
it was so ideal where I was born and the
family into which I was born and my
childhood was so ideal from my
perspective now of what's meaningful
is it I almost thought that maybe this
is a circumstantial proof
for the existence of
some prior existence where I chose to be
born in the sense that it's perfectly
unfolded yeah like and it would just uh
the farm had a nice Woods where you
could run
um my parents were
um
very benevolent people with no
meanness or hatred
um my older brother and younger brother
were just as athletic as me
my sister was healthy and nice looking I
mean the whole thing and the and the and
the fact that we didn't have money uh we
like uh pretty much had uh two at the
most three calls
um most of the time it was one call
um that is it during the whole period
right right I gotcha
the first one lasted I mean it was not
like it was we I think looking back on
it the fact that we were poor like I'm
like really you had to have a hole in
your shoe to get another pair of shoes I
remember that it was it really was fun
being that way but on the other hand
my father and his uh well my mother had
come from intellectual families so we
had all the books around and that type
of thing and and they spoke it's sort of
a prominent family it's I mean Wake
Forest area right right and that area it
was like we were the poorest of the
kitchens but the kitchens then nobody
was wealthy there wasn't a as far as I
know there were no that wasn't spilling
downhill your way whatever was going on
the rest of the kitchen family
well you know I don't think anybody was
very wealthy in in those days no matter
but it was a name people knew yeah yeah
because we had contributed a lot in the
way of politics
in various places and all that but so so
was your uh drive to you know succeed as
a doctor did that derive from not
wanting to be poor anymore or where did
that kind of ambition come from I think
that the fact
I think some of my life can be explained
for the fact that I thought I
experienced myself as being poor as a
child and I wanted to see what it was
like to to see
um you know where
people were
I'd at least wanted to get close to
experiencing
what I thought was wealthy I think that
that's what everybody there's a
Temptation that's the reason you know
you can almost see this person driving a
car a particular car if he's able to
eventually buy the car that he really
wants it's the one he saw when he was uh
younger kid yeah right in where she had
some money to back off but anyway
um yeah uh the
um no no I my grandfather had been
president of Wake Forest and was it
extraordinary
um
prominent kind of person so
I always had that to kind of fall back
on my father was if everything blows up
yeah
go back to Grandpa yeah
my father was a gentle kind of uh just a
very kind soft-spoken
a man with
um the ambition to be a farmer and
nothing much more Southern gentleman
well he had proven he could at least get
through law school but he just didn't
take a liken to it he quit so and in
some respects that his Evolution was
very predates your own it's a similar
cycle it is it's very similar and of all
the children I look like him and have a
lot of the same little characteristics
for what that's worth even though I had
the usual
conflicts with my father I wasn't like I
was a more I was closer to him than the
other two three
so so you ship off to Duke went to Duke
yeah the first year I was first in my
class really yeah and and I I was
thinking like geez I must be some sort
of Jewish you know
you know and then I joined a fraternity
and
um
I started drinking beer for about three
or four years I'd call it my beer
drinking years I think those are the
best years anybody can have frankly I
know what that's like yeah well drinking
beers with your friends at night and
talking whatever it is politics or
sports or whatever just that kind of
Fellowship is about as good as it ever
gets but anyway I enjoyed that part but
my grades dropped to about half where I
yeah that'll happen but I know what
that's like too you know and looking
back on it my hero was Nietzsche okay I
was planning to be some sort of mad
intellectual you know with books all
around me that was my goal
um
but
I I after being in the fraternity and
all like uh and and kind of leveling out
a little bit
um I thought that being a doctor was a
reasonable choice and and in a way it
was a choice out of cowardice in my case
because I could I was smart enough to to
do it
but it was a safe way to go through life
right almost like a lot of things that
look like the dangerous things for
instance the military it really is the
safe choice
but I made the safe choice I can
remember I just didn't know what I
wanted to do and uh jeez it's like
somebody staying in graduate school
that's right it's the burden of being
intelligent and well educated you have
that's right that's right well you know
I can't go be an actor I've got to go
that's right you know I need to go do
the thing that I am capable of doing the
other thing anxiety will smile upon me
Vietnam was raging at the time
so that was also in the people were
um they were going and getting killed I
had some fraternity brothers that were
killed the first year that they went
um so that's cool I figured I I'm not
gonna you know I'd already decide I'm
not going to run to Canada
and uh it's about a 10 chance that I'm
gonna get shot
so probably it makes sense just if you
get drafted just to go but I didn't like
the way they were Prosecuting that war
and I really don't like the way we
prosecuted these other Wars since
Vietnam and I really as a child didn't
like the way that we prosecuted the
Korean War
I was watching all this my whole life
I've been watching this stuff it is
absolutely disgraceful so stay in school
become a doctor yeah well it's a way to
bow out of that yeah you don't have to
to do it but
um it's not a bad way of life
particularly now nowadays the way our
society is the military is a very good
choice of a way to live
well I think we could it you know we
could do a little bit better with taking
care of the troops when they oh yeah you
know we're not doing such a good good
job of that you know then bumper
stickers that support your truth you
know the level of PTSD and the level of
care that these people deserve uh far
outweighs what they're getting you know
uh it it's well known by anybody that
reads history and that might not include
a lot of our politicians
but the troops you sometimes they come
back from these wars where the
politicians don't do so good and they
wreck the society
now the troops came back from Vietnam
after they had been uh to some extent
stabbed in the back and they didn't do
anything the same thing happened after
they drew a draw there with the first
Iraq thing now the same thing is
happening with these other two recent
Wars and you wonder
the reason the VA
is being in such bad repair
is that these politicians are not under
any threat from the returning soldiers
like they have been in other societies
and I'm thinking Germany
that the politicians here get away with
this kind of stuff the troops come back
and they just tolerate it well it's yeah
it's a tricky situation I mean the VA is
such a massive bureaucratic organization
that you would think that the troops
having the weapons would have some power
why do they let themselves be taken
advantage of like that by people who
have maybe they have paper pile but they
don't have any guns well I think that
the transparency of the internet is
starting to change that I mean you're
starting to see articles and people
speaking out and I think there's a
greater awareness of that situation than
maybe there was you know even a couple
years ago so you know good I hope that's
good I probably went off on a little
political thing that's all right but I
want to get to the doctor part yeah
that's all right hey Matt I got all day
I just don't want to keep you too long
from your skating no no it's a good
actually I like it I like your interview
I I I it's um I like the questions
um yeah and I went to I was um at Wake
Forest Medical School Bowman Gray is the
name of it and um they were the again it
was a fabulous time it was a great bunch
of people fantastic people student
fellow students some fantastic just
general and a lot of
heroic types I I had several mentors
that were just instill uh the top as far
as human beings the quality of the human
being and and just matter of fact when
you came you showed up right on time
um
I I always watch that with a new person
to see how close to the time it is okay
and I can tell you a lot about because
we used to watch uh one of the the head
of the neurologic department a guy named
James Toole and literally he would walk
from his house which was two miles away
and get on the elevator and do all that
and get through the hospital and to the
chamber where he was going to uh lecture
and would walk in right as the the hand
came to the exact time and we used to
notice he always did that you know so
and then and then you'll know you can
notice who who's before and after and
how long and like that and you see that
there's a span but the the some of the
other people I remember
um
there's the dean eventually the Dane
Jane uh uh Janeway
um dick Janeway
had been in the movies as a child
and he was just a spectacular person to
watch and
um to listen to and so I just I mean at
that the dean of the medical school had
been uh in the movies was it after he
was one of the Little Rascals
you know and that was a big thing in the
Seth we had no we had no I see
California and Hollywood and all like
that would be like
um
I don't know if the kids have anywhere
like that now you know because the world
it seems so accessible yeah but it was a
lot more yeah it would be way way
exotic and way out with exotic people I
mean that's just downright Bazaar that
one of The Little Rascals was the dean
of them he ended up being the dean of
the medical school
extraordinarily prominent but he was
just a um
just a unique and cool person you know
anyway it influenced me and and some
other people
um here and there uh so I stayed in
neurology you know these two had been in
neurology and um
it was an academic
thing like it was into his work and no
heavy lifting as uh not like on the
dairy farm that's right yeah I'd learned
the the zendor was an outdoors work by
the way I've done almost a hundred I've
done almost 100 episodes of this podcast
and I can't tell you how many people
that I've interviewed grew up on a dairy
farm oh really
yeah that's got to be something I don't
know there's got to be maybe yeah you
can do one of those meta studies right
I'm going to I think
um so so then you so you hang out a
shingle and start practicing yeah oh
yeah yeah so I had to uh I went the I
finished my
um residency I did two years at Emory
and then three years of Neurology at the
University of Miami and then I was in
the Navy
for two years I had I had a contract
post Vietnam Vietnam had come to an end
yeah so were you ROTC then or that they
put you through medical school no it was
a a kind of a special Plan called the
berry plan where you
um you signed a contract in medical
school that they let you finish your uh
training then you'd give them two years
later when you finished your training
and um I was assigned to the hospital in
Long Beach where Betty Ford and some of
the others made famous uh years later it
was a two-story
either two or four so I can't remember
but I I worked I was there for two years
and then I out that's all I had to do
which to me it was just a fabulous
experience I mean really being in the
military like being in the Navy
out on the boats for the shore Leaf part
it was just the you ran out of the the
camaraderie I mean it really is worth it
you were were you practicing medicine
yeah I was I was I I was the neurologist
uh that saw all neurological patients
between
um El Centro which I mean uh El Toro
which is about halfway up the road here
to L.A and then all the way up to
Oakland
so I I saw a lot of
Marines and people like that you know
the hospital was
um I'd say
they it was a a real real good
medium-sized hospital with surgery and
that type of thing but nothing really
exceptional when you when you were when
you say you're the you're the main
neurologist I mean were you
were you surgery as well no no no just
neurology which is mainly uh things like
seizures and and uh not operating on
spines but the reason it was really cool
is I had my I had a little office and I
had two Medics that were working we had
our um it was like a little
having been you know in training my
whole life and then coming to this it
was just fabulous it was it was a lot of
fun I just had to remember what you know
when to wear the white right
all right so the two so after that two
years do you stay in California yeah
stating I was in long I was living in
Long Beach which is close to there where
I was in the Navy
and um I'd worked up there for three
years in private practice with another
man another neurologist at one of the
hospitals in Long Beach and
um I would say at that time
I had almost
lived the American dream I had a house
and I had a call
and I was a I had
clothes for the first time I mean nice
clothes
and I had some prominence and I drove to
work and and
had a white coat and I did all that so I
kind of I got a good taste of what it
was like to be a doctor
in Long Beach
and
um
I was still kind of a loner that was
that's something that I've always been
kind of a loner I've had normal
relationships along the way but I was
still
living alone and this type of thing and
um
so
anyway
I reckon you know it's funny I'm kind of
thinking of the listeners you know at
this point like
no I don't think about that I'm not just
tell your story man but um I was
alone I started well I started smoking a
little marijuana here and there
and
um
began to have a few epiphanies okay
all right up until then I've been
absolutely straight you know like I mean
I was like an eagle matter of fact I was
the youngest uh Eagle Scout in the
country really yeah wow I got it in the
minimum amount of time
um I was 11 I think
when you got your Eagle Scout how many
badges it's like yeah well it's just so
that you got you've got to really work
on it all the time to advance it you can
only Advance it so fast so it was a
matter of seeing I could do it do it and
be the first one that another
you're this focused guy I mean when you
set your mind to something first in your
class you know until you start drinking
beer with your buddies but you know
right right and all this sort of thing
you're able to channel that side of your
you're able to channel the non-zone when
need be yeah yeah I'll tell you looking
back
I can see how which by the way that was
the part that I had the block on as you
get older you advance
kind of evolutionarily okay
and um I could see that in my past I
could have easily been a soldier
or a military type not a some sort of
killing person but you're very
regimented kind of regimented where it's
just the world you ignore the inside and
um I can also see
how I could have been a clerk in a clerk
variety the the same mind State and this
and that right checking the boxes and as
I've gotten older I've gotten closer to
being uh
you know it would almost it might be the
little bit I know about geronimo's life
is that he started out kind of a hothead
he ended up being more rational and
reasonable and wise at the end but I
might be wrong on that but
um
anyway
um
where was I so you were talking about uh
basically that your your medical
profession is progressing you're
starting to have a good living and then
uh and then you start yeah I started
smoking pot once in a while and things
are expanding or changing your
perspective is starting to shift yeah
yeah I was
um what I would say about is
not I was at least a prominent doctor at
the second biggest Hospital right there
in Long Beach
and um I can remember driving to work
and parking my call and looking back at
the hood and thinking like why don't I
paint some flowers on the hood of your
car yeah yeah now I didn't do it but I
could just I I got into that mindset
where I
um that young people get into when they
get exposed to marijuana I'd never
before that ever noticed cats
I'd never looked at jewelry mm-hmm I
never thought about
um
I never thought about
the visual feel in front of me as being
a visual feel as opposed to I always
thought it was a concrete whirl you know
in other words I I was I sort of could
see how
as a and by then I was credentialed and
well thought of and everything as a
doctor at a neurologist I was thinking
like
wow all that time I thought as a
neurologist I knew about the mind
I didn't know anything
and I was thinking like wow all of that
education I was an English major at Duke
and I read lots and lots of books and
all along the way and all that
I never had any insight into this way of
looking at the world
and and
so the first thing I did was get in
touch with the Indian the Hindus that
were working at the hospital
and um
they're pretty aware that there's
another way of experiencing the world
but they they've converted they had
converted over to our way so I was
thinking like wow that might be what
um is going on the mental institutions
you know a lot of the people that have
mental problems and whatnot
why don't I just quit and go into
Psychiatry and see if I can find out for
my own interests really because I I
wasn't married I had no responsibilities
except myself
um
what
um some of them are experiencing
and I I got in the program down here so
I just quit my
job up there and I came down here wow
you just straight oh wow so it's just
like that yeah yeah I did it pretty
quick
um I mean I have a friend down here that
was able that was kind of connected and
helped but they had a position down here
being San Diego uh UCSD yeah and
um I did I knew if I did two years I
could be credentialed in Psychiatry so
you had to do a residency I had to go
back so here I am a little bit of an
older guy in the class you know but
right how old were you at this point
well I'd gone through the Navy and took
three years so I was probably about
30. okay so not that old uh 31 maybe 32
somewhere in there and I did two more
years as a Psychiatry resident down here
which again
was just fantastic because of good
people uh friends and uh the environment
in San Diego it was such a nice place
but
um so all that
and then I figured halfway through the
I'd stop marijuana coal okay so I'd gone
why'd you do that you're you're starting
to have all these epiphanies you're
gonna paint the hood of your car and
it's changing your career
there must have been a dark side of that
too to make you want to stop I know what
that's probably the most intelligent
question you've asked
looking back on it that's where I made
my big mistake you should kept going but
I was alone or see I didn't smoke with
anybody I didn't have any uh I didn't
but this is not what responsible doctors
do John we know that yeah
that was the other thing like it was a
felony uh to be called not not like it
is now yeah and um
yeah so but everybody you know it wasn't
really I mean I didn't do anything uh
that was
harmful I mean it would be like having
an extra drink at uh around the weekend
I got you I got you but but anyway I got
down here I'd stopped cold and I was
straight again you know real straight
and
um
I decided to start a practice in
neurology and Psychiatry because no one
down here was double credentialed that
point yeah it's interesting I mean it
seems a natural Nexus between these two
things and it was so I started a
practice in downtown well over in
Hillcrest which is pill Hill
and um
by myself
had it I built up a nice little practice
doing the um pretty much standard
neurology
and
[Music]
um
I got married had a son got divorced
about a little short of two years later
after getting married
and I kept working and my practice uh
kind of changed over to a lot of
evaluations for disability and personal
injury and things like that so the
quality of it changed I began to make
what I thought was a lot of money
and I bought up a
then I bought an extra house and went
through that you know where I was
kind of experiencing what it was like to
have really good cause and all that
yeah you got the the V12 BMW right did
you get that you got a Ferrari I got a I
had a I had a Mondial Ferrari which uh
it was the only one of its type I mean I
thought it was a big deal that was the
first thing then that 12 cylinder which
is the worst
listen I know
and I do I don't think I'm not a journal
monophile but this would be everything
that they say about BMW is a lot of it's
true it's some of it's not true but what
I I find out with this 12 cylinder you'd
be flying along at
um say 45 miles an hour going down the
street and then suddenly it would just
turn off and go on it would go on some
sort of maybe two cylinders and and come
to a stop
and there were a lot of glitches other
glitches like that and the wheels and it
was because they figured all that stuff
out now but all right but at the time
not so good right but at least it looked
good right so you got the money yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then you
get this Exotic Animal Farm what is the
story with that well look yeah well I
bought this place out in Ramona up on
top of a mountain
looking down on everything and it was a
big house so six thousand
square foot house the three stories and
it had this big Wonder looking down on
everything I was thinking like whoa this
is really like I'm really turning into
some sort of yeah
you're a baller
I'm driving Ferrari and doing all this I
got this thing so I started behind all
these damn I had I got a a couple of
people working there for me like Foreman
and I so I started buying all these damn
exotic damn Birds and
yeah and and seriously looking back on
it's kind of funny I would even I even
dress like you can tell people that go
through this phenomenon whatever it is
of having more money like a lot of the
um celebrities you see them go through
this well they don't have anybody around
them to tell them to cut it out right
like just a bunch of yes people yeah
well I started like I felt like the rest
of y'all can wear a tie
and a jacket like that but I'm gonna
wear a special kind of jumpsuit you're
having like your own Michael Jackson
Ranch situation yeah exactly and this
was
um
you know I don't know if I did it before
Michael Jackson or did it he got the
idea from you uh well if he got the idea
from me but I did I did see a connection
there you know anyway
um you know it was a nice animal Plum we
had uh almost every kind of farm animal
there and I had it the best thing I had
was a two hump
bactrim camel which we gave eventually
to the zoo and
um we smuggled him a couple of weeks
that's a story that's a story in it so
well
it was this is an interesting story
um
I had the guy working for me was from
Oklahoma he had grown up on the farms
and whatnot back there
and so I put out a I had enough money
where I could put out a notice that I
was
looking to for a camel you know and I'd
pay anybody that came up well he he put
out the how do you put out the notice
how does that work uh I didn't do it
it's like a rich guy thing I know
exactly exactly yeah listen that's the
part I was playing like for instance
when I would go to an auction I would
sit on the front like jru and I was
trying to be kind of like jru and my um
Foreman who would address one down from
me so I was The prominent one he would
sit there and and do the bidding okay I
would kind of like I'd I tried to do the
whole thing a little bit like you know I
was in a way I was experimenting with
the whole
um image thing I reckon you know the
funniest you got to get a chuckle out of
this
I was putting together a small Clinic
which never came but it was in Vista
and I had some workers they are real
nice people and educated people
and I drove over to see how it was
coming in my Ferrari okay and I drove up
to the building that we had bought it
was a little building but it was
um and it's two stores they're standing
outside and I'm kind of dressed like in
some sort of special jumpsuit like my
own version of Elvis
he's our boss he's just the coolest and
they're standing there so I said a few
things kind of like you know kind of
superciliously and then I get back in
the Ferrari
and back up and slam right into a post
the universe is knocking on your door
already that was that was the beginning
of the zone is saying enough how much
longer are we gonna play this game yeah
exactly well no it it kind of taught me
that you're talking about earlier the
way you referred to this bigger uh
something uh takes over yourself during
Sports something like that like there's
a higher creative self whatever you call
it well
it's taught me that that there is a self
like that
but there's another little man
that's guarding a door that he comes
through
and that little guy won't open the door
if he doesn't totally approve of what he
sees you're doing okay it's like even
and so I was totally I was willing to so
to speak well I'll if there is a God
I'll go to hell you know I was I'd
already kind of it was a little bit like
well I'm going to play it this way
um
in a way and an analogy that
um I think in terms of now is held a bit
if you had one
uh
roulette wheel roll with tin and you had
to uh you had 10 chips
um
I think I was putting all my chips on
black
but now
I'm splitting my chips five on red and
five on black meaning what explain that
um all right thanks for asking me that
um
I am absolutely a thousand percent
devoted to the idea that there is a
higher
being of some kind that would make sense
of this world that we're living in as
humans
you could call that whatever it is God
okay
I'm totally devoted to the idea and the
fact that mankind should strive in this
direction as if he's an amateur and and
built in that image
I totally
disdain
the other way of thinking that it's just
a fluke this is what science would tell
us this is Luke
and what
people is just now that get what you can
and you're out of here there's no
afterlife anything like that
on that side
it seems to me that the left hemisphere
which is the analytical hemisphere comes
to that conclusion
and it will always come to that
conclusion
Hawking just made a very good uh TV
series uh program
about why I don't believe in God
and he can any by reason he gives the
most elegant argument who is this that
uh Stephen Hawking oh Hawking yeah and
it's recent too it's um so it's at the
end so to speak his final
so basically if you think this way
and if you're trained this way and then
you know the psychology of denial and
repression and all that kind of thing
and how we're all tempted to fool
ourselves
um you cannot ignore
this whole part and to me
it that means
that if you're balanced yourself
on two feet
you will have about half doubt
and about half devotion I see so that's
that's the idea of half on black and
half yeah yeah
the scientists
um and the the the typical sign the pure
scientists is putting all his chips on
black
it's an interesting thing because it
seems to me that the most brilliant of
the scientists have to engage the right
hemisphere of the brain because it
requires some level of imagination and
creativity and to me it's it's bizarre
because if you really drill down to say
quantum physics and you really begin to
understand how matter uh acts at the
subatomic particle level it's so
baffling and so extraordinary for
example I don't you know I'll botch it
but subatomic particles that are they're
like mirror images of each other that
could be you know on the opposite end of
the Earth that when one minute right
right it was the same way and all these
kinds of Crete it's crazy right so for
me when I look at that that just gives
me
I agree totally with what you've said
because if you follow quantum physics or
any of it down to it if you really
follow it down
it it does that for me too
and probably ought to back up and say
that
yeah that
the intelligent scientists the
intelligent scientists must see for
instance these uh paradoxes in quantum
physics
he must see that quantum physics that he
believes has taught been taught to
believe in is no more than a temporary
uh imagination of the human mind it's no
further than the human mind if you take
the brain that produces the mind at
least according to what we think you can
hold it in your hand like this
now so the scientists
it's got to say
if that's the fundamental level if he's
really understanding it at that level
and it's not just a temporary looking a
temporary uh imagination of the mind
because it's
then he must not be thinking that
something that that size
and it looks like a cabbage
can comprehend
the the under the underpinning of the
universe now think what how that
diminishes
the extent to which the universe
in other words you would think
that if a brain could comprehend the
true quantum physics that it really
exist
I mean if it could really I mean Way
Beyond the mathematics that we know now
and all that just way way so it really
is right on it that brain would have to
be it strong enough yeah well well what
it what what it says to me is that is
that we as human beings are extremely
arrogant in this idea that we believe
you know we're at the top of the food
chain and that we're capable of
understanding everything and it's and
it's that it's that um mindset that
pushes us forward to continually expand
and develop Technologies and all of this
but I think that it bears
you know it Bears recognizing that we
may never be able to understand these
things in the same way that you could
pick up a snake and try to teach that
snake how to understand the human
language for the rest of your life and
that the brain and that snake is not
it's just not Advanced enough to
understand that no matter what you do
and so I think we need to understand
that we're quite possibly missing that
extra lobe or two that would that would
allow us to comprehend these things our
ability to perceive
is so limited from the you know the
auditory frequencies that are we're able
to pick up on through the visual
spectrum that we're able to pursue all
these sorts of things are extremely
limiting and so for us to say oh well
you know it's it's this or that and
that's the definitive yes or no I think
is extremely arrogant and and I think it
it it hamstrings us from being able to
uh be in that place of of wonder where
we can allow that imagination to flow
and to really contemplate and embrace
the idea that there is more out there
and to be okay with that that's not a
threat to our you know time on the
Mortal coil yeah I like that I like
everything you just said I agree totally
so all right so so so you're driving the
Ferrari you got the crazy ranch with all
the animals and everything's going good
I mean what's going on
spiritually at this time in your life or
emotionally I mean are you starting to
kind of
question what's going on are you having
that rich guy thing where you're
thinking why am I not as happy as I
thought this would make me or what is
going on with you
well
um I believe that I the next thing that
started to happen was
gradual and that was a loss of my vision
so how long after this this sort of you
know collecting the crazy animals did
that start to creep in
um probably
oh boy I don't know it just back in the
90s
I can
I can tell you that I can remember for
about a year
when I would look it seemed like
everything was real dim
and um
I'd seen an ophthalmologist a few times
for uh to correct my glasses before ski
season
and uh he he told me that I was almost
blind
that according to the way they Define it
not a coordinate but and I was thinking
to myself and I even told him
I think it was during the Clinton
Administration I was just thinking that
the Democrats are
making too many advances you know what
this is that helicopter was coming after
you after yeah
that was really kind of funny isn't it
it's coincidental because I really did
think well golly if I'm disabled
then um and legally blind that means
that uh Clinton and the Democrats have
really made a lot of advances in
Congress
you're starting to lose it yeah no no I
was thinking that they've lowered the
threshold of the disability so far right
but um it was kind of a joke because I
enjoyed you're driving around you're
living your life and you're able to
function but then I when I was
um practicing this uh forensic neurology
I started
uh noticing that I couldn't really tell
if I'd seen somebody before or not so
um
I got my eyes checked by a bunch of
doctors and they all kind of agreed that
there was a a problem with optic atrophy
resulting from a severe case of druzen
crystals which is a
some kind of condition that people get
occasionally and um
so I I said well gosh my business is
going down
and I'm
a qualify you know I'm kind of getting
older anyway I'm unmarried I gotta I
don't have any mortgages
so I just put it all together
and figured like well I'll just
um
change you know and I like there had to
be some level of
profound unhappiness or dissatisfaction
going on with you
to really make you want to change that
drastically though
at the time
it must have been because it's almost
on some level okay you know you're gonna
have trouble practicing medicine with
this condition I mean is it was it
really prosopagnosia is it is that how
they that's that's what they you call it
oh it's the condition where you can't
you have difficulty
I think I could have continued
um but so there had to be some there
there was a momentum going on where this
this opportunity it's almost an
opportunity presented itself where it
said now I can finally his his uh I
don't know if you saw this documentary
they made on this but the turning point
that I can identify was a an old man
that I saw in the cafeteria in the
hospital when I was at the kind of at
the top part of working hard as a
regular doctor
and I'd mailed off to him
about uh how does a young good-looking
strapping guy like me get to be some old
gnarly character like he is right he's
like 91 years old it was nice um yeah
and he just he turned and shouted at me
I'll do what you want to
now
that was in the setting of me knowing
almost everything that a average doctor
should know about what's a good diet
what's the right thing to do for this
medicine I mean this particular disease
what how much do you do this what I'd
gone through a society where everything
was given to me of what to do
and
um it was the first time in my life that
I had ever thought gosh
if a person just does what he wants to
for instance
maybe bacon if I really like to eat
bacon maybe in my case
it's what I should be eating
you know and and I was thinking it
changed the whole Direction I was
thinking like
there's all this as you know the kind of
uh philosophic agreement that man
there's a certain set of categorical
imperatives inside of us
and um instead of and I saw medicine as
being like a bell-shaped curve where
they were
um a
taking everybody to be the same
um and for instance and it was just so
obvious in neurology because we expect
this nerve to innervate that particular
finger and soon
um but then I was thinking like whoa
if I just did exactly what I wanted to
what I really wanted to
really wanted to
and
um maybe it would guide me down a road
where at the end I would be
healthier and happier than I would have
been if I'd have tried to travel down
the road that I heard that you should
eat this and you should do this and
maybe you shouldn't do that and you
shouldn't think this kind of thought and
blah blah blah it just goes forever
right
um so having all having all that
knowledge of here's how you eat and live
to be healthy and happy inside you're
not happy I mean in the documentary you
you're self-described [ __ ] right
right and is that just in your your in
your ego and in your arrogance and
driving your Ferrari around yeah disdain
for your patients
yeah yeah kind of really just um
yeah it was a kind of a faustion thing I
can remember
um
I think it I'd I experienced the same
thing that Faust did
uh but Faust didn't get a way out
you know I I've been meaning to check on
that yesterday it's been a while
but I think you know you talk about
Fouts you talk about literature when I
look at your The Arc of your life it
really is it really is you could not a
great writer couldn't script these
dichotomies and these uh these you know
sort of the character Arc
better it's almost too good to be real
because you have
you had you're starting to lose your
eyesight
but that gives you the ability to see
you're a neurologist and then you suffer
from this neurological disorder that you
would think imprisons you as a result of
your many years of being a doctor and
yet that's what sets you free and you're
this loner who enjoys his time alone and
it develops this condition which you
would think would isolate you further
and that's what's created Greater
Community for yourself you know and this
idea that uh
that you stared at the end of your you
were staring at the end of your career
but that's really where your life began
it's beautiful you know and you couldn't
you couldn't dream that up if you wrote
it down somebody would say well that's
fiction
well you put it together Mighty
beautifully I appreciate you saying it
that way I uh where I'm at now
um
I live here
a half a block from the boardwalk that's
a two mile stretch of perfect skating
the feeling that I get when I skate
I know it's a Zone I can get in the zone
very easy that way and sustain it
my thoughts when I'm skating a superior
the type that people naturally have when
they're in the zone the way I relate to
the people and what they see up and down
the boardwalk
so it really is
about as close to Paradise
it's next I live next
to the Zone in a way but the paradise
isn't geographical for you the paradise
is is your ability to live within this
Zone like state that you're able to
access through what you do every day
which is get out and skate and high five
people and listen to music and tap into
you know that more Primal part of who
you are that allows you to connect with
you know your higher state of
consciousness that's exactly right I
call it
um the way I visualize it and and I can
tell you you understand all this type of
stuff
is that the ego
is
in a room that has a little door and in
front of that door
is a very small
little soldier who is you
when you were five years old
before the left hemisphere began to take
over he knows right and wrong
he knows uh when a person's arrogant and
when they're not
he knows a person the way everything
should be
and he watches you now you have to
please him
otherwise he won't open the door now
when he opens the door you just called
it the Primal uh part of ourselves I
call it the Christians call it the
Christ
I think that's what they mean by the
Christ
um the
um
I call it
because I don't want to restrict it I
think the Christ is a good name for it
but so that people don't get hung up on
whether or not that's correct is the
fundamental man
because I think the spirit is the same
thing that exists
if if there is a man that's equal when
if we are equal it's the fundamental man
is the thing okay and if he's in US
equally I guarantee you he's in the
birds and in the animals
and um he but he only comes out
and manifest himself
in the when a person's in the zone and
that's when that little guy
agrees to let him to it's safe and he
comes into the the
fundamental Christians would probably
say that this is you have to invite
Christ into your life
this is the the idea is that you have to
behave in such a way that this happens
to you
well I think that that uh
that that sense of
higher Consciousness is always there
um but but you have to do something
active to tap into it whether it's
skating or meditation or any variety of
things right
um you know sort of that idea that that
you know God never leaves you you leave
God it's always there and whatever your
concept of of that higher power is for
yourself you found a very specific and
unique way of accessing it your own
personal you know brand of tapping into
it which is fascinating but in many ways
it's it's your version of accessing a
meditative state that allows you to be a
more actualized version of yourself and
you know the biggest theme of this
podcast is how to unlock and Unleash
Your Best most authentic self so you
call it the fundamental man I sort of I
generally refer to it as the as a more
actualized version of of yourself but I
think it involves that regression of
tapping into that childlike nature that
exists within all of us that gets worn
away over the years all right let me
inject right here
please do
the way you do it is you do what you
want to
in other words that that self will find
its way like water
unless you restrict it
and if there's some barrier for instance
um
if you get to a um
you have to learn what you really want
to do how much do you really want to eat
how much do you really want to sleep how
much do you really want to be this
person or that person that would be this
and that and just gradually
cone down on it and what that will do is
prepare you it will open
the the path that's right for you well I
have a couple observations on that and
the first thing is that uh I might write
down a note because I don't want to
forget but the first idea is that most
people are so disconnected from
themselves that when you
sort of beckon them to
ask themselves what it is that they want
or sort of tell them go do what you want
most people don't even know what that is
that's right and it's not their fault
it's because
it's because this uh the non-zone as you
call it or our culture has created a
situation where where we are
disincentivized from tapping into that
part of our life and and it's not
considered acceptable or okay and we're
like you know in all honesty most people
are just trying to get through the day
they're trying to put food on the table
they're trying to take care of their
kids they got to pay the bills and who
has time to entertain this notion of of
you know what makes me happy or or what
it is that I that I want to do
um
and so I think that pushes buttons when
you say just do what you want to do I
think the knee-jer kind of reaction is
well good for you slo-mo you know you
had a you had a nest egg and you know
it's all fine and dandy but like I don't
have a nest egg you know I don't have
that luxury and you know my my story arc
isn't as dramatic as yours but it has
been a journey towards that uh trying to
you know tap into the fundamental man
and doing you know what I want to do and
I walked away from a law career you know
it's not it's not in certain respects
the themes are the same
um
and my response to that is generally
you know I'm not I'm not telling people
to go out and be irresponsible but
you've got to find a way to connect with
yourself and start to cultivate a better
relationship a healthier relationship
with yourself so that those ideas of
what you may want to be or may want to
express more fully start to
percolate up and then your life can be
about trying to find at first subtle
ways of expressing that more and as you
walk that path as we just said you know
that path will get laid out and those
bricks will start to fall in front of
you and it's a matter of following that
lead
I I think you've spoken it very well but
I want to um yeah please
for someone listening right now saying
because I'd be the first to say that
bebus was very wise when he told
Butthead there's always a catch
okay that's your sound bite but but I
want to say something to the people that
might be listening uh on this idea that
you should
um
you have to be responsible and make
money and and go and put food on the
table one of the things that surprised
me personally
is how much people liked me more when I
was pleasing myself
than when I was trying to please them
it's that it's that Buddhist idea of the
best way to heal the world is to heal
yourself it sounds selfish and
self-indulgent but there's a great truth
in that let's let's take an example like
um I can visualize someone listening to
one of your broke this broadcast
um
is struggling to make enough money to
put uh say give his family some stuff
something
but
if he doesn't really want to do that
okay
if there's something else that he really
wants to do
and he does it instead has the courage
to do it instead
then what will happen is his family will
be happier because he's happier doing
something that he really wants to do now
the the problem is
he may think he wants to do one thing
and he really doesn't you've got to know
what you really want to do because
Society has programmed you in such a way
that you figure like well if I really
want to do that it's got to be wrong
okay you've got to be careful uh to
really know what you want to do a lot of
people
um Ezra pound said that if you were
honest
uh the only things you'd really want to
do is make love and lie around
well because it but the point of that
extrapolating on that point really is
that the things that that make us happy
are incredibly simple that that you
think well that that can't be it like
for me yeah that's it I like you know
the sun is coming out right now I feel
the sun on my cheek and that makes me
happy or being out on a trail with the
sun on my back and and being able to
connect with my breath or being you know
in the ocean swimming these are the
things that make me genuinely happy and
I remember as I started to engage those
more I thought
that's kind of great this is what kids
do this can't be you know what it is but
you know we're hardwired with millions
of years of DNA to you know live in a
more Primal State than we've created for
ourselves and and I think that you know
you're an example of
what it what happens when you can
connect with that kind of Primal urge
and and the direction that that can lead
you in but I think it does go back to
exactly what you said which is you got
to get right with yourself you know
we're we're we're so bombarded with
signals and distractions and information
that it's impossible to be silent with
yourself to be able to tap into the
frequency of that
that higher Consciousness that is trying
to speak to you and it's work you know
that doesn't happen just because or you
can't just flick a switch like you have
to put energy and time into that in
order to ensure that whatever decision
you do make about where you're going to
invest your time in the future in a way
that will make you happy is indeed
the appropriate path for you is that
yeah resonate with what where you're
coming from
yes
um
it's all in the word want
what does you know it's interesting like
because the words are applying to
[Music]
um
something that's very hard to to know
really what does a person really want
um
well that that's the it's subjective
it's an experience yeah yeah I reckon
um
you're talking about
um that we're wired a certain way
one way you could say that this thing
may be working is that biologic tissue
as to it get to a certain stage of
development to create a mind like a to
have a brain with a mind
and then the mind has to get to a
certain a stage of evolvement or
Evolution to produce
what we would call The Zone okay
and the zone
is a natural
the result of a Natural Evolution so
that
um
well give you an example in the TV
series it's excellent called the Vikings
I don't know if you've seen that it's
very friend on that show actually oh
really well good for him which one is he
uh his name's Donna log I don't know the
name of his character okay he's a
bearded guy with long hair but they all
are right yeah yeah I haven't watched
the show well
according to the archeology and whatnot
it's very accurate it's a good program
and
um you can tell that they're hierarchy
they first off they're uh and and this
would be true of the Nordic cultures
that they were extremely uh loyal to law
that they really were and they they were
societies uh that believed in the law
the law of nature no no their law their
law
it wasn't as uh they weren't societies
of men all right below the I mean even
the chief and people that had to obey
the law
and then in the hierarchy that was a
Chieftain that we're all the Warlord
that we're all familiar with but above
the warlord
was the Mystic
and the Mystic was the only one
that there was no reprisal against you
couldn't kill the Mystic I mean Warlords
had to defend themselves tenure
exactly the Mystic all right so if if
you look at the Bible the hierarchy is
the Mystic the Top If You Look at
um
well Native American cultures Native
American culture that's right the Mystic
so the mystical thought of the
personality we think is the top and we
care less about animals that we think
don't and have that if we think a dog's
got it we don't eat dogs over here
because we think that a lot of people
think that there's a heaven for human
there's going to be dogs in there
because they're not any less Divine than
we are and so
basically the the idea
is
um
that the Mystic whatever his desires are
and whatever he thinks this is the top
and I I don't mean the epileptic I'm
talking about the true Mystic
um and that those things are very
consistent with all the biblical and
ancient writings have said even Marcus
Aurelius and people like that
um and that is what we really want most
of us
is a peace of mind
uh aggression and revenge
are attractive
as uh The Deadly Sins the seven deadly
sins all of them are attractive to all
of us
but
a state of peace and Good Will and love
is preferred that's the one we want
and I think that we're all chasing it
but we're chasing it in the wrong way
because we're in a world where we think
that the way to get that is to
sort of you know you know succeed in our
modern definition of the term and then
we get there and then we think
what happened or what's wrong or why
aren't I not feeling the way that I
thought that I would feel when I got
here and then you feel ripped off and
then you feel resentful
and that can lead you down a very dark
path of despair
yeah so
you found a way out
found a way so I want to know did you
just
have this Epiphany and literally
overnight sell all your stuff I mean
what was the logistics of how that all
went down
um
well I quit and I started doing exactly
what I wanted
I mean that was my theme every day I um
everything fell into place so nicely
it seemed like to me like it was a gift
from God to get me out of my medical
State my
um I mean so you have this 91 year old
gentleman says do what you want and did
you kind of ruminate on that for a while
or how long was it before you just
decided yeah I did I mean I started
doing it immediately I started doing
what I wanted I would
um of course I felt guilty as I'll get
out for the first few years I remember
when I wake up I could hear the freeway
thinking like I should be on the freeway
you know after a while you don't hear
the freeway anymore that doesn't sound
the freeway
and what are your uh your peers your
colleagues your extended family members
chirping into your ears around this time
well almost everybody thought I was
probably uh nuts or sort of semi-nuts
um some of my family members kind of
politely came out and visited me to do
an intervention yeah that type of thing
right
um the uh I mean it never really came to
the surface and and I never could tell
at a point like that as always you have
a streak of paranoia so you don't know
for sure you know just how how much a
person is sort of evaluating your the
level of your mental faculties well it's
a tricky thing because I think the
dividing line between dementia and
expansion or the Quest for enlightenment
those it's like a Venn diagram that
perhaps could overlap and especially the
way that we perceive somebody who makes
a counterculture decision to be you know
for lack of a better term a Seeker
that's not something that's going to be
embraced that's something that's going
to be marginalized and and uh and kind
of the words that would come out of the
mouth of that person sound crazy to
somebody else when in fact
maybe these are the words that we should
all be eating
well
to me I know both sides
I think it's like
combat you've got it in the middle third
of life you cannot always do what you
want to you have to make a living
and there's some realities there I mean
we have to survive
and but if you get a chance
as much as you can I think you ought to
stay in contact with the other side The
Zone but what I think Christ called the
kingdom of God it's inside you and you
should get try to call back some small
part of the day
a week to be in touch with that so that
later
you can get you can just dive right into
it and be in that state as much as
possible when you're older yeah I mean
in the documentary you say that you were
lost in a rational world it's a rational
world and the question that you were
asking yourself is on a daily basis how
much of your life
was devoted to spirituality and how much
of your life was devoted to financial
gain and when that balance tipped too
far in the wrong direction that's really
when you started asking yourself these
questions and the Universe I guess you
could say in certain respects really
conspired to answer that question for
you it did I feel like I'm in therapy
sometimes you summarize these things so
perfectly
I mean this is really helping me
understand about that but we haven't
even gone to the skating part right like
in the top 50 things of you know like
what makes me happy like where does it
how do you
you know how does it boil down to
putting on the rollerblades I mean at
some point you must have been doing this
already where you realize this is
something that made you happy but where
does it where does the the sort of
dawning realization come in that this is
literally what you want to just
basically do all day every day okay
there's a song it's where the lyric
um is If I Were a Rich Man I would pray
all day uh-huh that's in a pedal on the
roof If I Were a Rich Man I'd spend all
day praying well I'd identify the the
best state of mind and and we're all no
different states of mind but the best
for me was what I call the top spiritual
state of mind uh or the zone and that I
discovered when I was skiing I'm taking
a picture okay yeah I I discovered when
I was skiing uh I would go skiing every
winter oh whoops hold on do that one
more time sorry yeah
new film there
I gotta take a Polaroid I had done
enough skiing over the years that I knew
that the sliding
um and I'd investigated this lateral
acceleration or momentum
um gives a certain feeling that the
reason people get the feeling of
exhilaration um carnival rides or racing
around a corner in the car
um is the the acceleration it spans the
inner the experience of inner the inner
ear experience of balance it's the site
so it's the side to side motion yeah
it's got to be a force that's right it's
got to be a force
um it's uh neurologically it activates a
whole nother set of receptors okay
anyway I'd experimented with this over
the years with skiing so that at the top
of the hill I would get as close as I
could meditatively by standing there
and then
um I would I'd kind of gauge the size in
the extent of this then I would when I
was calling turns
I would uh see that it got much larger
and more intense okay so it it dawned on
me that the that this was the source of
uh Investments when Hillary they asked
Hillary why climb mountains
yeah not Hillary Clinton
[Laughter]
no um
sir admin yeah yeah he as you know he
said because they're there
but there's a real answer to that
question
the real reason has to do with balance
when a person is in a precarious
situation for instance climbing the wall
of a mountain or something like that the
sense of balance it spans and what that
is it's at least in my own judgment The
Identical thing
which the um
Moses and other people that wrote the
first part of the whole Bible
called the I am experience in other
words
the soul and the sense of balance
identical to each other
that's what I'm saying interesting yeah
so the meditator what he's doing
is he's concentrating on part of the the
uh since the century apparatus for
balance which plant wants to plumb
itself with the sun of the Earth
yeah there's there's well this idea of I
am kind of Harkens back to Hindu texts
and the idea of self and Oneness right
right being present and meditation
techniques that that revolve around
doing doing just that anchoring yourself
like envisioning that that anchor
dropping down from uh the base of your
spine when you're in that level right
right right in the earth so okay so
Buddha
could do that really this was assumed
that he could really do it well
to the center of the earth now suppose
he had ahead inline skates
or a teacup at Disneyland see what I'm
saying his meditative experience would
have gotten larger
that's what happens to all the people
that are that get addicted to these
sliding Sports
for instance the surfer the
skateboarding surfing skiing on and on
it's the exhilaration of the I am
experience which results
from adding the acceleration component
that is the force component
to the
um the stable component that's plumbed
to the sun of the earth so what is it
neurologically that's going on in the
inner ear that allows you to kind of
experience that like neurologically
um
okay here's what I the the way from my
knowledge of the anatomy and so on and
it's incredibly
a lot of details right which is for the
layperson but the layperson if you look
at the brain you can remember that a big
part of the brain is the lower part of
the cerebellum it's about a third of the
size of the of the rest of the brain the
major part of the brain
the cerebellum is wired primarily into
uh the inner ear
okay and to some extent to a large
extent and a sort of a parallel system
which is at the tip of the nerves that
is a proprioceptive sense all right the
um
that part of the brain
picks up information
from the inner ear
from the
semicircular canals and from the outer
lists which are plumbed to the Center of
the Earth
on both sides and there's a background
feeling which we call the sense of
balance it's the sixth sense it's the
same sense that the Ancients would call
thought existed in the pineal gland
the neurologists don't make any identity
of the sense of balance
with the I am experience but
meditatively if you watch it from the
inside while you change your sense of
balance and you know that this is what
they're doing or at least it's
consistent with what they're doing when
they meditate and then how much of our
Sports have to do with acceleration and
then the feeling of the zone and you put
it all together
it's a state
of epiphany it's a state of I exist as a
subjective entity
I am what I am which is this now what
this is is the result at least if we go
back to a scientific way of looking at
it
of these receptors stimulating part of
the brain which as a resp uh result
of curved space or gravity
or gravity waves
and um these waves are obviously most of
them are coming from the Sun of the
Earth from the gravity of the Earth
but most uh but a certain number come
from out of from the Sun and the Moon
and uh it has a constant uh background
it's a little bit like micro background
Act
of the mind for instance we we have six
senses you can count them site is a
predominant one when you see something
this
Sixth Sense is is just there
right it's on low
humor
sounds right you smell and eat something
it's on low hum you go through life as
if it didn't exist well it doesn't the
sense of balance never really gets
bumped in with the other senses we don't
really acknowledge it as one of our
senses that's right because it is
identical to
us that's what I'm thinking is it well
because you wouldn't know what it would
be like to be you can't be born without
a sense of balance yeah I mean you can
have a tweaked sense of balance I
suppose but you you couldn't be born
without
what it feels like to feel gravity right
so we wouldn't know we would that would
be like and there's no place in the
universe where there's no absolutely no
gravity
um
I think that uh you can tell that it it
will accommodate to itself like if you
go spin on a circle after a certain
period you'll you'll come it'll it'll
come balance out
um
it by what I can uh it's experience and
watch is that there's sort of a limit of
time of how long a person can literally
stay
glued in the zone in epiphanous state
like from acceleration okay and it's a
matter of a few minutes probably but in
essence what you're saying is that is
that by by uh engaging your body in
these lateral movements that you you can
access through rollerblading or surfing
or
skateboarding or what have you it's
really just a means to access a state of
higher Consciousness that would be a
little bit more work if you were just
meditating so it's almost like it it
does the work for you so you're not
fighting your mind trying to get into
that state it's just a natural result of
the motion that you're putting your body
through exactly and that allows so it's
a moving meditation for you that's right
and that that takes us back to the idea
that that the athletes
are fundamentally the same group of
people that were worshiping in other
forms in others in other words they are
what they're doing when they get
addicted and they do it fanatically
it's a type of worship
it's identical to the same feeling that
a person would get on Sunday if he went
and sat quietly in a church or synagogue
or something like that it said
um
fundamentally
that's
that's got to be the unifying if there's
anything that unifies
religions
and gets any follower in whatsoever
would have to have a component of it
would have to be the same state of mind
right well it's that is definitely a
unifying threat through every you know
aspiration the athlete here is finding
and he is also and that that's what I'm
saying is in that county he doesn't
think of himself as being a worshiper
but if you really look at it and
thinking that's what he's doing he's a
monk when you though that's what I was
just going to say I was going to say you
you're actually you you live a very
monk-like existence incredibly simple
and you're you wake up and your day is
about devotion
it is yeah by engaging in this
meditative state of higher Consciousness
I I live for it and when I'm not in it
um I'm literally just waiting to die
like
um I can see what the average doctor
observed that I knew that retired lived
two years and then dead
usually because at least the way doctors
have been up until recently maybe they
still are they really didn't have much
of a life other than just working away
as a doctor that was their whole thing
so they were totally unprepared to be
anything except maybe to drink you know
at the last I I think that um
I think marijuana is a better choice
than drinking you know yeah I think you
can I think what I found out and I'll
put in a plug for this if anybody's
still listening to this prod podcast oh
they're listening I've I've
um experienced uh life to I'm 71 and
I've seen this right and wrong and
what's sin and what's ethical like I can
I taken a good look at all that
and um
I can
wait a minute
[Music]
what did you argue your memory yeah jog
my memory so you were talking about uh
accessing a higher state of
consciousness oh oh yeah yeah back on
here's the ethical system
assuming that this model of the Mind Is
Right
okay generally right
the ethical system is that everybody
should if they can
maintain
and and take care of one sin
I think we were meant to have one sin or
one vice president smoking cigarettes
would be considered a vice
smoking marijuana is a vice
indiscriminate sex frequent sex is a
vice all gluttony is a vice on and on
and on all these people that have lived
before us they were right these are
vices
now part of us does well if we have one
Vice
we cherish it we take care of it so I'm
getting an idea of what your voice is
yeah
your life will fall apart if you add a
second Vice or third base
as a physician I've never seen an
alcoholic who had only one Vice
have any problem I've never seen a
smoker that had only that Vice have a
problem I've never even seen a heroin
addict or an amphetamine addict that had
only that particular thing the point is
I think that we can all live longer if
we have one Vice and we perfect it
but not add to now if you don't need a
vice you can be judgmental and that
counts as a vice well I don't think
anybody's without Vice on some level
my point is to have only one and perfect
it but why not why not work to try to
overcome all your vices imperfectly of
course we're human beings we're going to
err we're gonna you know Screw Up and
all these sorts of things but why not
commit yourself to always be trying to
be better well there's no reason not to
if that's what you want to do
but um there's a couple of things in
favor of having one voice
Mark Twain identified the first one that
is you have something to stop
well if you start feeling too bad okay
or if the doctor tells you you've got to
stop there's always one last thing yeah
one last thing you can do now it also
gives you something to do in the last
part of your life
you can think to yourself to have enough
time left
that would justify changing my vice
and this is a Worthy topic of your own
existential
in other words the question you ask to
stop a vice is a lot more interesting
than to be a person who doesn't have a
vice that decides maybe to start one
yeah I mean I think that that
like I said I think we all have we all
have our vices in one form or another
that are you know ramped up to whatever
volume they're at but I don't think
there's anyone walking the planet who's
who's Vice free you know completely
um and I think the people that are the
most judgmental about other people's
vices are probably harboring secret
vices of their own that they don't want
other people to know about uh
I don't know how we got down this town
uh I think that having one the the main
thing I tell the young people out here
now try to get through them seriously
the point is because they're drinking
smoking right they're doing everything
the the what they need to do is cone
down on one Vise and just do one because
the person just because so their own
life won't deteriorate right but I think
that that I mean what if you're one Vice
is crack cocaine you know it's not
that's not going to end well I bet
yeah yeah but I think that's a purely
hypothetical one I don't think there's
ever been a person who had only that
particular Vice
he probably had several vices and there
may be an exception to this but but I
think that for instance there have been
people that function quite well on
amphetamines but they use the ones that
get in trouble drank and use
amphetamines well if you're yeah I mean
if you're if you're an addict you're an
addict in the addict anyway well I'm in
recovery I have been for years but I
know you know one truth which is that
you know just because I'm not drinking
doesn't mean that the addict isn't alive
and well yeah yeah there's something
else to latch onto
so that's that's where the work is all
right now my my question to you and that
that is would be
have if you don't have any vices at this
time would you be happier to select
another Vice that was not maybe
destructive as uh alcohol and then have
that in other words
and I'm not asking if you have any vices
I have plenty but go ahead but well
anyway it's like I think that in other
words I'm putting a plug in for one Vice
everybody should take it a concern
because if you have no vices
you are isolated from the best part of
humanity
you have a tendency to be judgmental
which is the worst possible as I said
you turn into an [ __ ] well I think
another way of putting that really is
just to say to to embrace uh the
imperfections of what it means to be
human and yeah exactly because they're
perfect and to not and to not be hard on
yourself because you're not perfect or
holding yourself up to some kind of
impossible standard and to you know
really just try to enjoy your life a
little bit more all right I mean
um
but getting back to the skating right so
[Laughter]
we got to talk about that a little bit
more so what I want to know is uh I want
to know like what's what's the typical
day in the life well I get up about nine
nine o'clock or something like that have
drank coffee watch the news
uh why are you doing that that's not
monk like you shouldn't you shouldn't be
watching the news the poisoning your
brain I know I I've always been addicted
yeah to I'm one of those people and I
and I I know the virtue of of stopping
paying attention to
all that but I still I love history and
I love the I frankly
it comes under the heading that I can't
see when people say God loves man
I always thought that might be a
stretching it like there's nothing that
lovable about man but I could see God
being fond of us because
there are things about man constants
politics
that I'm fond of watching I'd like to
listen to it I like the idea of the
historical
um the way man has been to the last few
a couple of thousand years and being a
part of that and and uh the whole thing
even if I was God and had nothing to I
would to do but watch it I would
probably enjoy watching it I enjoy
Fox News I enjoy watching the other
networks just the playoff I enjoy the
propaganda
I enjoy Putin I enjoy Assad no wonder
you got a skate all day clear your brain
of all that nonsense I enjoy the whole
fact that the human beings have involved
to this extent and and that I got to to
watch it and be a part of it I think
it's just uh exciting and interesting
now as far as
um
evolving using it for involvement no
it's not at all that's not at all
meditative and it's very different no as
soon as I leave that and start skating
I'm in a whole nother situation so when
you start to skate how long does it take
you to access that's that zone like
right right now I can do it like in a
second or two because I've worked at it
yeah I just as soon as I call it right
it's right up here
um it's at the top of the hill
I'll take a left turn and start down the
hill and as soon as I do
um I will drop into a state of mind
which is just infinitely different than
and it but it took me a couple years
like the the first trick is to
uh get in the zone
you have to find a what I call a gate
that is something to help you get in it
um whatever it is you're doing then the
key is as soon as you get in it to stay
in it
and I just worked at it for the first
few years I was skating I had this every
day and night to work and so now I can
drop right into it it'll be like when I
was in the Navy I did some research on
hypnosis
and one time I had
um
seven different Marines as in the
hospitalist patients with this study and
this phenomenon because there were a lot
of people feigning and have been
sinkable episodes in the young people
and um I found out that some people you
can hypnotize uh very quickly like in a
moment other people takes a long process
okay so there's a lot of variation of
how quick a person can get into the zone
some people naturally can do it very
quickly and others can't
I was sold in between it it would I
could get in it but to stay in it more
than say a 30 seconds or a minute
it's a practice right I mean practice
they say with meditation you're sitting
there and then a thought pops up and you
go down that train for a while and then
you go oh yeah I'm not supposed to be
doing it right right right you know when
you start off you can't sit still for
five minutes and it's just you have to
work at it so it's it's
um that's the whole trick and the and
what I can tell
is that
the zone
in Amazing Grace they make a distinction
between sight and vision
um
um and and all religious types do sight
and vision and there's that distinction
exists in your own life yeah right the
site the site that you lost that gave
you the Visions right right when I'm
skating I'm not seeing anything I'm
seeing the vision obviously it's like
I'm not looking at anything
but the the the whole picture
is it's in the world of the Unseen which
by the way you said something about time
uh space stretching it does stretch it
changes the thing that makes us think
that it doesn't change is that we rely
on Vision once you begin to study space
when you're not looking at it you learn
that it does change size according to
movement just like Einstein and them
said even though it's very small but we
are a lot smaller than we think
in other words the visual world we live
in which includes us has given us a
false idea of size and also uh where
things are relative to each other and
and when you skate in and out and around
uh people you learn that there's a lot
more space than you thought that was
than your mind is seeing
and you learn that there's a account of
a super throughness of space which is
added to by acceleration for instance
it's a lot harder to to hit a person if
he's in one state of acceleration that
is plumbed to the Earth say standing
still and you're in another state of
acceleration which is rotating say in a
pendulum which would be causing a turn
back and forth so
you can change the space
you have to believe that you in the
vision that you right that you're seeing
with your mind's eye and what is and
what is it about your specific technique
where you have one leg up and your arms
in front of you that enhances you
accessing that zone like State this
that I don't have the final answer to
that question it's been I I was asked
that a bunch of times all I can say is
there's some advantage
the feeling
is maximized by being on one foot
in that position
it seems like like if if I try to
maximize the feeling of of
um
of acceleration or this feeling of the
zone of being meditative which is the
feeling I'm trying to get not
acceleration
uh per se but the feeling is that I will
naturally go into certain positions
number one is I think that the hands
I've noticed that the hands and the
fingers will naturally fall into certain
positions in meditation
the positions you can see it in the
ancient religious paintings that they
will often have the two fingers like
this you know and then the Buddha
position is is very common too and
people that deeply meditated
these are the these are uh automatic
positions that have to do with the body
language and so on of being meditative
and all I can say is a lot of birds seem
to be meditating standing on one foot
um well it's a it's a single anchor to
the Center of the Earth it saves both
feet down they're moving around which
one's the anchor right one one leg down
yeah and it's a straight it's straight
shot down right yeah yeah it could be
you know I think of it that way even
though you know it's kind of like a
moving yoga pose though and it's like
Warriors
exactly that's what exactly that's
exactly what it is and it adds to the
meditative experience once you get now
because you have to go in and out of
people
if you meditate usually you're alone
right think about this to get meditative
and to be right next to your fellow man
of all types of all ages
and close enough that you could touch
him
and you're moving by so that nothing is
harmful going to happen
that what I've experienced being that
close to strangers continually in the
and I'm in the zone completely in the
zone me it meditative like it'd be like
Buddha walks out of his Zone and a sleep
walks right into the crowd of people and
begins to experience them in their
normal state
to me it's the type of anthropology
that's uh it's just unreal uh
what I've learned about man the mankind
by being in this world of strangers next
to them and among them in a state of
meditation it's sort of like taking the
red pill and the Matrix and being able
to see through the Maya the illusion
yeah and so what is your you know when
you look look out upon mankind or you're
watching the news in the morning
you know what is it that you're seeing
that we're not seeing
good I love your questions brother
um
when I'm in the best state of mind the
best the ultimate
meditative state of mind that I've so
far gotten is I feel that everything
exactly the way it is is the best
possible
in other words I wouldn't want to change
anything like even a death or somebody
getting cancer or something like that I
would in other words I see the whole
thing and I get close enough I can see
it like wow it already is the best the
in like for instance uh the dialectic of
trying to figure out whether we should
do this or this in politics or something
like that
um the fact that we don't do this or
this but somehow another kind of waiver
in between with a lot of argument
I think could conceivably if we would
contest it would be the best
in other words we only know that the
world can be one way
it ends up whatever this way or that it
ends up one way so in a way we have a
choice whether we believe that that's
the ultimate way it could have been or
whether it had gone off in some other
way
that it would have ended up worse
so I sort of see that uh in the best
acts of meditation that I wouldn't want
to change anything
um not even a man's hostility to to each
other I wouldn't go around saying love
your brother and all that or I wouldn't
cure the poor or the alcoholic I would I
would see the whole thing
as a absolute perfect uh kind of
um
subjective organism that's evolving and
growing like a a plant or something like
that and that everything people in
different stages of this involvement if
you look at the individuals but the
whole thing is on some sort of
um path where it's feeling its way
into the future
and it knows what it's doing okay that
it it it's even
in small ways uh that there that you
can't second-guess God I I sort of feel
that now I can when I feel a little less
meditative and Petty
I can think of all sorts of ways that I
would improve the world and do this and
that it but every every one of those
times it seems to me I've fallen back
into the non-zone as if I would know
for instance right you're you're you're
placing your judgment
on something that you you're not you
don't have all the information take this
uh situation we've got here with the um
immigration okay or the uh we're gonna
get political here uh well it's just an
example uh say well what to do with the
children okay that have come to our
border
this is a good example you could take
either one One Direction or the other
direction
you can justify either direction and you
could probably say well it's going to
fall somewhere just kind of in the
middle and it'll just kind of ends up
out there somewhere where you could
other historians can write both sides as
if they knew that it happened this way
or that way and you'll never really
because it's just gonna all kind of
disappear instead of being well we do
this and this we keep our country at the
Integrity of our country that's the
definition of a country or no I'm gonna
prove what a good person I am you know
so like somebody up in San Francisco you
know who's going to let everybody in you
know to show what a wonderful person she
is San Francisco a bleeding hard liberal
I mean you can see a conservative guy
yeah you can see the justification for
both positions and and I I personally
kind of see that that's this is it it's
not something that I personally
know the answer to and
um it though I was tempted I grew up in
a society see I was born in 1943
we were born in the middle of a
patriotic time I was
and there was a country here called
America we called it America the United
States
us the U.S we still call it that don't
we
let's stop being a country though during
the uh what what you've got now is kind
of a territory
okay because there's a uh they're not
treating it strictly as a country
they're not I mean the government has
taken on another relationship to this
area of the continent and so I can see I
grew up thinking we had a country but
I've been able to see
well if nobody else wants to kind of if
half of them don't want a country in the
old-fashioned sense where you know we're
really in it for a country
um
I can go either way I can see the
advantage of going either way the
um I can see that you can justify
yourself believe in either side
um there's no nothing
specifically more correct about
globalism
then there's about uh provincialism
uh I mean like you say I could cone down
and just care about this right here
or I could care about whether there's
life on other
planets I mean
in a way it's I've just
I kind of see that it doesn't really you
this is a thing that's in the hands of
of the people and in history not in my
hands yeah right well I mean essentially
what you're saying is it's not for you
to to judge yeah
yeah if I can I think the I have to say
I think that
there's two sides I I personally am
tilted to thinking that if if you were
in politics and you have the
responsibility for your fellow man
and the fiduciary responsibility then
it's your responsibility to be a patriot
okay and that I think
is a responsibility that is being not
taken seriously by a lot of our leaders
true patriotism well it depends on your
definition of patriotism exactly but it
does we don't want to go too far down up
a political uh black hole here right you
know what I mean it's blacker and
Blacker no well you go down it so uh
yeah we should probably wrap it up we've
been going for over two hours that's
good well you're a good conversation
with this all just you
um but I wanted to wrap it up kind of
with one uh final thought
which is something you've said in the in
the beautiful documentary which we
didn't even really talk about but I
thought Josh Eisenberg did an amazing
job with that movie and I was so touched
by it and uh and after I watched it I
was like I gotta find this guy I gotta
talk to him so I'm so happy that we're
sitting here and doing this and it was
it was uh I can't imagine the result of
that film being at South by Southwest
and I heard you went to the screening
right that must have been something and
then for it to be in the New York Times
how is that changed your life or has it
well it it hadn't changed my life at all
but
I've I've gotten just absolute amazing
feedback from all Corners
um all it seems to me that almost
everybody that saw it
really liked it now I wouldn't have
necessarily expected that even though it
was a nice little documentary but for
some reason
almost everybody and I mean I personally
I've heard from hundreds and maybe
thousands and it's coming from all over
Europe and South America and um uh not
just here at Ireland there were some
people from Ireland yesterday that came
that you know German knocking on your
door all the time now or just out on the
boardwalk looking for you or no no you
know I think of that little place there
is gonna One Day end up like when you're
in Amsterdam you go look at where Van
Gogh lived and it's like a little place
like that
like I had a photographer here the other
day taking a picture of where I lived
but nobody bothers me as a matter of
fact you know like
I feel that I'm in a protected company
my uh oh well you're you're uh you're an
institution down here there's nobody in
this community that doesn't know who you
are and I would imagine that they you
know I don't know like it's probably
cool for them that you got this exposure
but they probably also feel protective
of you oh yeah yeah yeah he's ours like
don't get too close sir that's what
happens with them yeah that's right you
know I remember
um
thinking that let's see the guy that up
in San Francisco that
um
Tony Bennett
uh he's well he he tries to live a
normal life is what I I saw on TV one
time and goes to the grocery store and
that type of thing
I thought at the time when I saw it I
was thinking like that's what a person
ought to do is really just stay simple
and like they are
and still be who they are now that's all
I do I don't change I'm in this state of
mind but frankly
um
it doesn't it hadn't changed my I think
I'm old enough where it has not affected
my ego I had a guy
um I used to have an ego now I got that
part but but I but now
um you know one of the interviews this
lady was saying slo-mo has life figured
out that slowly has life figured out she
said it about three or four times I'm
standing there going like gosh that's a
disappointment because if if I've got it
figured out right I mean that that grabs
headline you know that's a catchy
headline that will get people to listen
or go to that website or what have you
but you know but I'm very modest about
the slow-mo the I feel that I'm on a
mission from God as as they would have
said in The Blues Brothers
I've not done anything to commercialize
it which if I was early in my life
you're wearing just so people listening
if you've watched the documentary you're
wearing the same shirt the same hat and
the same cargo shorts that you were
wearing in the documentary right now
yeah
yeah I'm just um
no my my whole existence now is
um
is the world of subjectivity and what
um what we really are on the on the side
of subjectivity and and you said in the
documentary and this is probably a great
place to close it that you felt you feel
that you're on the tip of a great
Iceberg of Consciousness so maybe you
can just expand on that a little bit
um the image the matter thanks again for
a great question that the to me the
metaphor of
um an iceberg is a perfect metaphor for
a lot of things
um the main thing is the human being
himself
the tip of the iceberg
is usually we think of it as being the
part that's the the tips of various
nearby icebergs that say they're talking
to each other and one of them knows that
this one knows so and so the specifics
but the major part of the iceberg is
generic it's under the sea
um
it doesn't fit the the tip of the
iceberg but when I'm skating
I feel like I'm at the tip
of what is the human mind
it's the top the very Peak
and but
what I see when I relate to other people
now it's all below
it's all generic
for instance with all due respect to
your individual person
I see you as one more of these and
you've been here before and before
before before and you've had other
capacities other lives the generic and
this is the tip of the iceberg at this
moment
you know
and you're carrying
the Consciousness which is uh you're
obviously very much aware of your
self-awareness
and it's part of the iceberg
but it's always been there and it came
from under the sea
and it'll pop back up like another tip
another tip
and so on I like that
thanks for talking to me slamo peace
plants
[Music]
foreign